how did we get here like that's the
question right now um I'm Anna I mean
you guys certainly deserve a thank you
video I'm gonna try to keep this between
I don't want to jump cut the [ __ ] out of
this one I just want to keep it you know
a Jeremy do his fans and keep it all
pure but a million subscribers just
happened for those of you who don't know
I just hit 1 million subscribers that's
it's a lot of subscribers it's almost an
unfathomable unquantifiable amount that
you can actually quantify but yeah it
certainly deserves a video and so I just
wanted a lot of people have asked me my
story and how would it did starting
YouTube some people want to see my
filming room that makes me nervous I
don't know why it's like showing people
just the regular guy behind the Great
and Powerful oz or something like that
which totally sounds douchey for me to
say but ok how first of all before I get
to the how absurd sincere actual thank
you is 1 million people who said you
know what I will click right there and
see more I want to see what this [ __ ]
has to say click boom 1 million times I
don't even know I have another eye in my
head I don't know how you guys thought
that that would be a good idea I thank
you for it these YouTube has led to some
system cool [ __ ] um it really gave me a
path when I didn't have a path I was a
projection inside a movie theater
frustrated because he sees so many
people and find the groove in their life
like oh that's totally what I'm gonna do
and there I was starting movies in a
digital theater that didn't need to have
me there but the boss was cool and the
company was cool so they they were like
it'll keep Jeremy as a projectionist but
I was and then I just started YouTube as
a hobby and here's here's a story I had
my friends and I back in my 2000
something probably 2006 um we bought a
camera I bought a camera bout a Canon XL
to those of you don't know it's this be
stray look at the sizes [ __ ] thing
this thing is so this is standard def
also this is actually the camera I used
before I filmed in high def on a much
smaller camera which is what I'm using
right now but I had that because my
friends and I were like we're gonna make
short film it's gonna be awesome and so
we made a couple and it's a grueling
process it really is just hard it's
difficult and sometimes quite horrendous
and so uh I wasn't having fun doing it
so we didn't do it anymore because we
were just getting stressed out and angry
at each other for zero reason whatsoever
but I had this camera and my friends
were like you should totally do YouTube
Matt was like I'm not that interesting I
don't know what you guys are smoking but
don't think that I'm that fascinating so
I didn't do it and then I saw
Transformers Revenge of the following
transformers too and I had a youtube
channel called movie man 191 and I just
so didn't like Transformers Revenge of
the Fallen I was like I think I'm gonna
talk about that on YouTube give me a
skew to use my huge overpriced camera so
why not I'm in credit card debt because
of the camera so why not so set it up
and I actually did a thing where I
talked about Star Trek x-men origins
Wolverine and transformers ruins of the
Fallen and I didn't even put it up I
filmed it and did nothing with it and
then time went on and I was like you
know what I'm gonna do that transformer
thing one more time so I filmed another
segment of me just talking about
transformers and I cut it together and
put it up didn't tell anyone that I did
I just wanted to see what people said
and people were kind they thought it was
good that was funny you know the very
kind words from the get-go which is
super cool because I know how
demoralisation can get I have to assume
there are people who started youtube who
got some book you you don't know and
then they just stopped which is sucks
it's a tragedy but to be on YouTube you
got to have thick skin which I don't
always have you've seen me get
frustrated with people on Twitter or the
comment sections in my videos it happens
and I totally get it
and if it happens early on I get that
people will probably just stop doing it
which I'm sorry if that's happened to
you but uh so I didn't tell anyone about
it and somehow the people at my work
found out about it and they just clicked
found my channel found the review turned
it on while I was there and I was like
this is either going to inspire me to do
more videos or I'm going to stop as of
now and they were they were all laughing
and my former boss still professes us
his favorite video I've ever done so I
got I got lucky in that sense and just I
mean it was just really was a cycle of
really positive reinforcement I was had
I was having fun doing I still am having
fun doing it it's been like six and a
half years I have a million six and a
half years I've seen people do it
quicker I've seen people do it slower
but we got there but it still is a hobby
like I tell people people like what do
you do for a job I'm like I don't have a
job I have a hobby that I get money from
I don't have a job I'm pretty much
unemployed I'm an unemployed man child
with thick earrings all around me and I
talk about you know movies um and so
after that just kept doing it and you
that first hundred subscribers is the
biggest Heil ever feel on YouTube it's
that first time you see the digits go
BAM you're like whoa extra zero holy
[ __ ] and that's why 1 million is mind
blowing because it's very much the same
feeling it's a milestone because that
first hundred you're like oh I'm gonna
do this on it oh I'm gonna keep doing
this and now a million it's not the end
it's not like it ends no it uh million
piece no a millions word it continued
millions kind of like the Master Sword
and Zelda where it's like alright you
got that thing now we've only just begun
and then your adventure starts from
there that's a Link to the Past for
people who might not get the reference
and like that's not an ocarina that's
argh arenas the best and so yeah that's
that's how I started and if anyone wants
to start YouTube reviews or YouTube
whatever my only advice is have fun be
yourself and be honest because your
integrity is everything on here if you
start bullshitting people they're going
to see they're not dumb and just it's
the the sincerity that you'll come with
will be why people watch you and and one
thing also is people seem to think that
YouTube is a get-rich-quick scheme it's
not so if you're like oh I'm totally
going to get quick money on YouTube it
doesn't work that way
and if you go into it with that mindset
you're just gonna get frustrated I had
no idea that that was a thing
and so from personal experience again I
kind of like took the route it was
ignorance is bliss I just didn't know
that you can make money doing YouTube so
I just did it because for the [ __ ] of it
because it was fun and yeah it's really
cool seeing the feedback you're talking
to the people and people who Google go
to get believe you respond to you're
like what are you talking about dude I
do it is remarkable how people seem to
think like I've met fans and it's almost
like they react like they're meeting a
celebrity and to me I'm like I don't
know why you're reacting that way but
it's awesome and I appreciate it it
makes me feel very good but I am so just
me I was literally watching the Food
Network downstairs in my house where we
are filming this is my bedroom by the
way this [ __ ] but I'm going to bed and
if the magic is happening yeah chicks
dig my my surroundings um but uh it's
always just a mind-blowing thing and I'm
so completely not in the I have a
million subscribers mindset I'm still in
the I have that first hundred you know
which is fun you know again it keeps it
a hobby and I and so if you're gonna do
this do it as a hobby first and if you
get money they fantastic but don't do
YouTube for the sake of getting money um
but I just wanted to you know I when I'm
kind of on a tangent like I'm giving
advice like okay I'm gonna give you
pearls it really wasn't my intention I
just wanted to thank you guys and give
you a quick story we turned out to be a
long story but thank you very much a
million subscribers is baffling and it's
unfathomable but thank you from the
bottom of my heart seriously you guys
like I said gave me something to eat
it's gonna sound super cheesy it gave me
a legacy like it gave me a legacy worth
having it gave me something worth
working towards every week and that's
the thing about it which makes it great
is that I don't have to really scrape
for [ __ ] a run out of ideas it's like
every week I get to talk about movies
which is
funny because I knew a couple people
when I was younger one person in
particular was like you know movie
characters I was watching sisqual
neighbor he was like movie critics
people who talk about movies for a
living if they think that is anything
worth doing there sadly mistaken and now
I'm doing this and he's like good job
man super awesome we are all proud it's
really funny they should kind of changes
like that when you have different
perspective but no seriously thank you
and now I'm gonna do so I'm gonna do so
I almost froze up there I was like
should i I'm gonna do something that
really makes me nervous because I feel
vulnerable it literally is like seeing
me naked is kind of how I feel I'm gonna
show you guys a peek behind the curtain
you guys want to see where I film so
let's see where I film all right we we
got to be quiet because I think there
might be some people editing in there or
a filming possibly so all right we got
to go in really slowly and quiet hello
anyone doing that oh there's not because
I don't have an editor and there's no
one else who films here
hold on let me get a hold of this camera
alright this is the room this is where
the magic really happens and if I get to
the corner it is it's just a bedroom in
my house that's all it is
sorry if these lights are playing hell
on your eyes but yeah looking at it that
Karpis because in standing there there
are two spots on the right feel like
there are two spots in the rug where my
like my feet you can tell right here
like those are footprints because I film
here all every time I feel my I film
here um but yeah I just look around it's
like a light that lights me as I'm
standing there to lights that light the
green screen green screens like 40 bucks
on Amazon some miscellaneous [ __ ] over
here I have like a bunch of bulbs
because bulbs wear out and you just want
to have them all so I think I literally
went there and bought every bulb they
had mrs. just some old monitor laptop
bags kylo Ren thing like this is a weird
that I've used I used that for
terminator
there's my tour de force pipe a gun for
when the movies really get bad and my do
those my cop glasses you remember the
speeding ticket I got so I'm talking
about but Ellen mic stand
oh and Star Wars curtain cape you cannot
forget that reminds us all what's
awesome but uh oh and a lint roller
because they sometimes you get lint on
your suit and you need to with you need
to fix that but here I'll show you what
it takes to make a video check it out
the mic right here BAM
just like that that's how you make a
YouTube video and I I'm doing this to
show you guys first of all you know what
no we can't not don't do it it's too
loose nothing but hold on I'm gonna get
it ah stop whoa that took way too long
that's why we do jump cuts ladies and
gentlemen but no I wanted to show you
guys this because I mention there were
some people out there like oh I can't
start YouTube I don't have a budget
clearly neither do i I have no budget
whatsoever I zero budget I mean one can
argue I have a budget now but it's kind
of get it as you go you know I already
had the camera but the camera is like a
thousand bucks tripod granted the tripod
is pretty expensive but I had it for my
xl2 I would get a less expensive one
hundred dollars the zoom h4n the little
audio thing that I record with that's
like 300 I think the microphone is 300
again I had that for years the light set
is $300 green screens like 45 but that's
it and once you buy it you have it you
can just do whatever so what one-time
purchase of all that stuff
and I was able to do YouTube until now
my gear is unchanged except the audio
equipment and the the camera the rest of
this [ __ ] same stuff I've always used
same setup I have always used but I do
it to show you that you don't need a lot
you don't need everything you don't need
this huge budget you don't need backing
you don't need a crew you see you if you
want to do it just do it because
apparently that excusive like well i
don't have a lot of money is now gone
I've taken that from you and I'm really
sorry about that
but you you no longer have that and even
if it's not YouTube there's something
else I'm just showing you that if one
guy can get a million people to watch
him or consistently 300,000 people it's
its Trek first to watch him then
you can do that thing that you want to
do - you don't need everything you get
as you go so just do it do that thing
you know it's just that is the reason I
showed you this room I showed you this
room because is it underwhelming
absolutely and it should be because just
normal people doing normal thing well I
don't know if YouTube videos are normal
normal people just doing hobbies it's
what it is is what I am it's what we are
it's what we do us so uh yeah just do
your thing whatever it is YouTube or
otherwise just do the thing start and if
if you don't get a lot of momentum at
first keep doing it you'll get momentum
and then you know maybe you can just
kind of ground out a little piece of
life for yourself
- like I did but yeah again thank you
thank you all for for watching and
subscribing my hair just won't you um I
really appreciate it I seriously do from
the bottom of my heart thank you very
much and we hit a million and so I have
no intention of stopping so there will
probably be at two million video maybe
three who knows who knows how far we'll
go I have no intention of stopping it's
really funny side story before I go I
work with the screen jockey screw on
screen junkies plus did that for one of
a couple reasons one because the screen
junkies crew they're actually a lot of
fun to work with - one of the logistics
insane logistic I gave them that I give
given anybody who's ever want to do
things with me doesn't always work out
there like I'm always like out the gate
I'm like my channel remains the same
unchanged untouched as if this other
thing isn't happening and some companies
have been like well I'm like well then
you can kindly go [ __ ] yourself so I
have to assume they went had sex with
themselves but with the screen junkies
guys and II was like no I guess I'm a
content creator first is what he always
said so I felt really good about doing
that with them um - it's a game show
it's a lot different than what I usually
do my regular norm here in this little
room that you've now seen and three it
gives me an excuse to wear my different
suits
I suppose I could wear them here but it
just is an excuse to do it so that's why
I did it one of the reasons but yeah
thank you very much you guys for
everything seriously and as always if
you like what you've seen here and
you've won is if you want anymore I have
really [ __ ] it up a lot um this is why
we use jump cuts and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more thank you for clicking right
here to see more for so long so many
times for so often I love you